en retrait des troupes militaires
françaises au mali pour est il
déstabilisé la région c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage de ce soir et pour en
parler nous sommes avec baba ahmed
journalistes à bamako et dominique
trinquant ancien général et ancien chef
de la mission militaire française à
l'onu également expert en géostratégie
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france je
commence avec vous baba ahmed quelles
conséquences aurait un retrait des
troupes françaises au mali 1 plusieurs
de plusieurs parce que tout simplement
un retrait des troupes comme ça ça se
prépare ça besoin d je vous rappelle que
les américains a entamé le processus de
retrait de leurs militaires c'est une
longue période donc donc de retrait des
troupes de ces jeunes normalement quand
ya la bonne volonté de toutes les
parties
ça doit se faire longue période mais si
vous prenez l'exemple par exemple de la
guinée la guinée voulait aller tout de
suite à l'indépendance en 1958
les retraits de colons étaient brusque
c'est de cette manière que le pays était
à terre pendant longtemps
donc c'est clair que faire que passer
tout de suite ce point c'est à dire tout
de suite arriver les troupes françaises
pour un choc
1 les conséquences sont déballés jusqu'à
à celle de la libye par exemple où il ya
eu d'intervention et les pays retrouve
dans cette position soit 10 ans après
encan c'est un scénario possible selon
vous ce retrait éventuel des troupes
françaises au mali
alors il faut rappeler deux choses la
première c'est que tout proche mais
surtout ma vie à la demande du
gouvernement malien est d'ailleurs plus
globalement dans la région du g5 sahel
elle y sont à la demande des présidents
de chacun des pays du g5 ça c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que le président
macron et l'a dit les forces françaises
ne sont pas là pour rester ad vitam
aeternam
il est évident qu'un retrait doit être
anticipé mais là la configuration est
plus particulière ce qu'explique
président macro aujourd'hui c'est que si
le gouvernement malien veut j'allais
dire négocier avec des mouvements
jihadistes je parle pas de tous les
mouvements qui pourraient pour
l'autonomie du nord du mali mais je
parle des mouvements tels que dahesh ou
ou accueilli ces mouvements là on ne
peut pas négocier avec eux et donc si le
gouvernement malien choisissez de
négocier et donc d'admettre une certaine
place assise mouvement la france n'a
plus sa place dans cette région la
france est là bas je le répète à la
demande des pays de la région pour
combattre l'extrémisme islamiste et au
passage la france a amené beaucoup
d'européens avec des financements
européens en particulier pour essayé
d'activer le développement dans cette
région
donc la question se pose clairement
aujourd'hui et elle est dans les mains
bien sûr du gouvernement malien du
colonel keïta qui est président
maintenant décidé par le conseil
constitutionnel mais aussi la décision
aujourd'hui de la cedeao parce que c'est
d'un avant tout des décisions
européennes
la france n'est jamais qu'en appui des
africains là dedans alors vous parler de
la situation avec le terrorisme sur
place depuis 2012 le mali fait face à
une poussée djihadistes qui est partie
du nord du nord et qui a plongé le pays
dans une crise sécuritaire elle s'est
étendue au centre du pays aujourd'hui
a vu une attaque jihadiste présumé a eu
lieu dans le sud du pays alors ben ahmed
est ce que vous craignez que
l'avertissement des manuels macro
n'aggrave la situation sur place
c'est à dire que moi j'ai l'habitude de
répéter salle ici c'est la france c'est
à dire la solution aujourd'hui à
apporter par barkan et par la force
européenne
hélas n'est pas une solution qui permet
de lutter contre les trucs c'est comme
un malade sur vous voulez vous nous
donnez un comprimé dans la 12 s'ils sont
les médicaments qu'il doit bien compris
mais dans la douce et 1000 par exemple
barkan ça fait peut-être 500
donc c'est donc du coup c'est le
médicament n'est pas à la hauteur du
traitement du mal
c'est ce que je voulais dire leurs
opérations par cartes au mali depuis
2013 donc ça fait neuf ans une bande de
guerre je vous rapelle que au début
c'était uniquement les normes des
extrémismes
rubens redescendu dans les centres alors
que l'opération d'alcan et la force
européenne sont là il a actuellement ils
sont en train de redescendre vers le sud
donc c'est pour cela que les maliens
sont exacerbées il ya une présence des
militaires européens
des militaires français et de tous
quelques onze mille casques bleus qui
sont là tous pour les malades mais dans
les faits ces chiffres n'est pas et est
en bas de la solution c'est à dire que
se peut ses traits peut se tromper et ce
qui fait que peut-être les grandes
villes comme bamako tombouctou mopti et
les grandes villes peu cette opération
peut le maintenir
n est ce pas avec les troupes maliennes
peut les maintenir en dehors des
attaques de groupes extrémistes
mais fondamentalement de façon générale
ça ne protège pas les mali est donc
temps que cette opération barque en
reste comme tel
ne s'adaptaient pas utiliser les pays
donc comme vous les voyez depuis a eu de
grands fois où nous au mali
aujourd'hui vous avez la conférence
d'entente nationale et vous avez le
dialogue inclusif
c'est des gros de vraiment des grands
rassemblements où les maliens se sont
mis ensemble et lors de ce grand
rassemblement
ils ont demandé à ce que les autorités
maliennes puissent dialoguer puisse
prendre contact avec les leaders des
groupes extrémistes qui sont des maliens
c'est à dire les touareg yade agace ali
le pull qui gère les centres qui est en
mode la coface l'ikeca il se trouve que
le des personnalités ont des liens avec
al-qaïda et al qaïda étaient les
occidentaux notamment l'union les
américains sont en guerre avec se
désorganise avec cette organisation là
et je vois mal les maris maintenu sa
part son partenariat avec et l'union
européenne et les etats unis et dames et
en même temps de dialoguer avec des
groupes liés à al qaîda
on va parler longtemps de ce sommet de
la cedeao
dominique traquant selon vous que peut
décider aujourd'hui la cedeao des
sanctions peut-être est-ce que ils
peuvent décider en schéma de sortie de
crise
écoutez c'est très difficile la cedeao
lors du premier putsch avait imposé des
sanctions qu'elle a fini par lever une
fois que le le gouvernement malien de
l'époque avait changé un peu sa position
elle les avait levé parce que pour la
population malienne c'est absolument
terrible
les sanctions le mali a besoin
développement je reviens un peu sur ce
qui a été dit il évidemment que les
forces militaires ne peuvent pas
apporter la sécurité complète c'est aux
états de se déployer dans les zones dans
lesquelles sont actuellement déployés
les dialyses parce que les et yanis en
train d'installer un pseudo état et donc
remplace l'état dans ces zones là donc
pour ce développement là il faut
naturellement combattre les armes à la
main les dialyses pour leur montrer
qu'ils ne gagneront pas les armes à la
main qu'ils en viennent à la négociation
et que le développement arrive
simplement la négociation ne peut pas se
faire avec tout le monde
aqmi le le mali n'est qu'une petite
partie de son développement sans
développement il est mondiale donc vous
comprenez bien pour reprendre ce qui
vient d'être dit précédemment qu'on ne
peut pas négocier avec eux parce qu'une
fois qu'ils auront acquis une assise au
mali
c'est vers d'autres pays en particulier
l'ouest africain voire l'europe ils se
déploieront donc il faut bien faire
attention à l' équilibre de
l'utilisation de la force armée du
développement et de l'installation de
l'état dans cette zone et ses cinq sets
cette coordination de ces trois actions
qui doit pouvoir déboucher sur quelque
chose pour l'avenir du mali parce que je
rappelle qu'on parle du g5 sahel mais le
véritable enfant malade c'est le mali
baba ahmed la cedeao est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle va privilégier le
dialogue elle a invité en jeu je vais
rappeler à ces nigauds ita à ce sommet
quel signal est ce qu'elle l'on voit
déstabilisation du mali et la porte de
la déstabilisation de la cdo et j'espère
que tous les paramètres pour les anges
et seront analysées au pain pour
reprendre la mer de sujets aujourd'hui
les filles du mali est dans une position
tellement tragique de magie qui est si
la cedeao prendre des sanctions dures
les pays risque des risques d'être dans
des situations extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement difficile pour sa population
pour lui même et dans l'avenir même du
piper étrange pour la simple raison
comme j'ai dit vous avez le nord qu'il
n'est pas totalement sous contrôle de
l'état vous avez les centres qui n'est
pas certains partis ne sont pas
totalement sous le contrôle de l'état et
là mina et les sécurités se développe
actuellement le centre
ce qui fait que le pays est déjà fragile
alors des sanctions
ils vont fragiliser les pays et risque
d'amener les pays vers l'inconnu
ce nouvel épisode ce que je ne souhaite
pas pour mon pays par contre par contre
si des sanctions allaient dans des
sanctions ciblées et tout ça mais comme
je le dis et je les pense honnêtement
que si les sanctions sont vont aller
dans le sens des sanctions dures les
pays risque d'être dans une situation
compliquée donc comme j'ai dit le
thermomètre de la situation au mali est
avec la cie bien merci beaucoup monsieur
pour vos éclairages merci baba ahmed de
journalistes à bamako et merci à vous
dominique trinquent ancien général et
ancien chef de la mission militaire
française à l'onu et expert en
géostratégie re